how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in double the story I want to
start with his about a friend of mine
and I will call the friend Sam although
that wasn't his name and Sam came to me
one day Sam was an executive vice
president and other in other words a
very senior super important extremely
well paid individual he came to me one
day and he said Margaret I think I'm
going to leave my job I said wow you
know you've been there a long time
you're in this very powerful well-paid
job why do you want to leave do you have
another job no okay so what's the
problem well he said you know I've known
for about two years that one of my
colleagues sexually harasses the young
women in his department and everybody
knows everybody knows you know when we
have executive outings he'll bring one
of his latest young women along with him
you know the rest of us bring our
spouses he comes with one of these women
it's awkward it's embarrassing and I
feel ashamed of us that we allow this to
continue and I just don't want to be
associated with it anymore so I've
decided to leave and I think at that
point he expected me to say well done
Sam you are a man of principle you get
out of this place as fast as you can so
I'm going to pause the story there
because one ending of it could be sam
leaves and he gets a job somewhere else
and he lives happily ever after
but one of the things I was thinking
about is I was having this conversation
with Sam is what's going on here what's
really happening in Sam's head what's he
thinking well one of the things that sam
was thinking was I don't like this it
reflects badly on me I don't want to be
associated with it so go away that sound
thinking about Sam he's thinking it's
not my job to fix this right he's
thinking it's not my job to fix this I'm
not head of HR right sexual harassment
isn't on my job description so it's not
my job to fix it he's thinking well
maybe nobody else minds and as it
happens Sam is Egyptian so maybe he's
thinking maybe this is OK in England
what do I know he's thinking if I raise
this topic it's gonna be an argument
well I don't like arguments nobody likes
arguments I'm conflict averse most
people are conflict of us so I don't
want to have this argument it's much up
better easier to leave so it's not my
job maybe other people think it's okay
right I'm conflict of us I've tried
really hard let's say let's say for two
years to ignore it so I've stayed really
busy so that
I've kept it at bay but somehow it won't
leave me alone and and it's too
difficult it's just too difficult so
instead of doing anything I'm just gonna
leave so Sam is a textbook example of
someone who's willfully blind he's been
willfully blind for two years and he's
still willfully blind even though he can
see what's happening because he cannot
see a single positive outcome except for
him to preserve himself by leaving and
you might think Sam is an unusual
example I think he may be having an
experience it's quite likely everyone in
this room has had not exactly the same
but working in situations where there
things that aren't quite right and it's
not quite our job to do anything about
them and we might be wrong and we want
to be a good we want to do a good job
which bind me at large we think means
let's not have a fight let's be jovial
good citizens let's fit in get your
tickets for the world's largest music
and philosophy festival how the light
gets in dog